all right phoenix and david
phoenix uh where did you grow up where
are you from originally i'm from hialeah
florida
you're from florida yes that's northern
florida hialeah
yeah
and uh tell me about uh
your family growing up
um
[Music]
my family is just a loving family
i accept when i was five
my
father's brother
was raping me
and he got caught in the action and my
dad of course beat you know the crap out
of him
and of course to this day he's in prison
i
been going to school that
i was bad on the drugs and alcohol
that they would take me to institutes
instead for bad children
and
it led on to me doing more drugs because
the institutes there were
they weren't good like they weren't
providing
for me to learn and i have a hard time
learning things
and so you know i was doing crack and i
was doing cocaine in the institute
and i would always skip to go get liquor
and all that
and of course i would always dress like
i was older
to make it you know seem like i was
older
and i was only by that time i was only
12.
and i met i met up with an ex-boyfriend
and
it turned out he was sex trafficking
little girls and i was one of them
so
that happened for about three to four
years
and then after that this is florida
yeah yeah this is in
miami beach i'm i'm thinking i'm
guessing
and um
yeah it was a bunch of
big trailer trucks thingies like you
know those trailers
that the trucks haul
you know where they go and ship them off
and stuff like that so
but we weren't shipped off we were just
being held there
and of course you know they'll put me in
gunpoint to do drugs
and to
you know have sexual
do sexual favors for other men
and then
i got out of that that's how i know i'm
a lot picker
so that i mean you know i escaped a lot
of girls didn't a lot of them died
after that
i met up with another man
that turned out to be
a very bad man because he wanted me i
was in a hotel
and he changed me to the room so i
wouldn't leave
and he would beat me of course you know
make me do drugs
you know do other stuff to me
and of course like i said i'm a i'm a
lock picker you know so when he left
i had
you know i had the little bub wire
and tweezer and
clicked up that
chain
from my
my legs
and
ran away when i ran away i
went back to my mom and dad
how i did it i don't know how i got back
there but i know miami and florida so
well so
um
i didn't go to the hospital i didn't
want to report anything because the last
thing i needed for my family to be in
danger because of the situation i was in
so i kept my mouth shut
um after that i was with my
a lot of times with my ex-boyfriends and
of course they would beat me they would
you know put me on drugs they would rape
me
uh
um they would you know if i didn't do
something right they i have my scars
here i got broken i did did something
wrong well i didn't do it right which is
going the street and you know i didn't
want to be a prostitute i didn't want my
name to be like that
so
he threw me down and broke my arm
and
you know gave me more drugs so i didn't
feel the pain
um
then i got hit by a car these were all
my exes
and all of them were abusive
and of course they would say
if you know if we can have you then no
one can and you know they try to fake my
death of course
i have a
excessive word in the brain and my mom
recently told me that i might have a
tumor
in my brain and then i have uh i died in
my sleep that's why me and my husband
don't want to be separated when we go to
shelters they want to separate us but
they don't know my condition
and when i go to sleep i will
i stop breathing my heart will stop
and i died in my husband's arm four
times
so
you know he'd bring me back to life and
just tell me just breathe and everything
won't be okay and you know i may be
dying
but i'm not i'm not going to die without
a fight
you know i don't want to go to a
hospital because the last thing we need
is to go and get a coverage shot
and with my health problems and his
health problems we will die from it
so we just
survived we just live life
trying to make it home as we should have
been home but
where is home
castle rock colorado okay tell me
phoenix before we go on to david tell me
about your early childhood with your
parents
it was fine everything was fine and
there was no
no no views nothing like that no they
never hit me yeah i mean you know a
little spanking here and there but
that's normal got it but other than that
we're okay they're just bad luck with
boyfriends yeah so david um
where were you from originally
originally from denver colorado denver
and
you grew up in a
with mom and dad
i grew up with my grandparents
when i was born i suffered from a severe
heart condition
my dad
was my stepdad
my biological father stepped out of my
mom's life when she got pregnant with me
um so my dad he my stepdad got in my
mom's life he not only adopted me but uh
due to the circumstances that you know
the the
way that they
i guess you want to say the
living conditions that they had they
couldn't keep me
uh i have a twin sister which she died
she was stillborn she was born a minute
before me
i made it out
struggling and barely able
to breathe and the doctors literally
told my grandparents i wouldn't make it
through the night
um
well
that was kind of how that went so my
grandparents raised me
um lived in florida
um when i was about
i was about
two and a half three years old my uncle
married a woman named connie
and
no one suspected no one knew
at the age of four
she would
drink scotch
shot glass and she pulled me off in a
room and she'd get me naked
of course play with me
and she let me play with her
and uh she always tell me it's going to
be okay
you know just don't tell anybody
you're old i was four and uh
she'd always tell me you know if you
tell
your grandma and grandpa i'm going to
have you taken away i'm going to put you
and i'm put you in a child in a
children's home
so i used to scare me
so
this led on kept going on for about
three years when i was seven years old i
finally
got up the guts to tell my grandpa
at the time my uncle was he was a
sheriff with the dade county sheriff's
department
um he freaked out
of course
things led to another and my aunt left
the picture real quick
because of her doing what she'd done to
me when i was nine years old i got
caught smoking dope
in the back of my grandparents house
i grew up very rebellious
a great home my grandparent my grandpa
was executive vice president of pap's
blue ribbon beer
my grandmother she was
a nurse
i was very rebellious
did a lot of stupid things
a lot
um by the time i was 11
i was already shooting heroin smoking
heroin doing cocaine
stealing cars brand new car automobiles
off of parking lots
um taking them chop shops selling them
getting money for it
um
time i was 12
my drug addiction led so heavy that i
was spending upwards of 500 to a
thousand dollars every two days
just for my drug habit
of course
i was hanging out with gangs um
doing
just doing stupid things
um
all of the drugs that i led and i was
doing led into my
i was doing opiates
alpana's
xanax bars oxycontin stellatins lower
tabs i was doing uppers and downers at a
time together
i died
i died twice odd three times
first time i died i was dead 19 minutes
doctors had told my grandparents that i
wouldn't make it
i was in an induced coma for about three
months came out of it two months after i
got out of the hospital i was dead again
um i hated life
um
drug addiction was so bad in my life
that it had complete control over me
uh relationships didn't really exist
uh with me for very long because i
was so heavy into my drugs
my grandparents
and my parents they
had put me in a
it was called methodist medical center
was eighth floor at methodist medical
center it was foot as for children it
was drug addicts and had severe drug
addictions
um
upon talking to a psychologist and a
psychiatrist they had explained to me or
explained to my grandparents exactly why
i was the way i was and it was because
of all the sex
of me getting molested
and
the things that i put up with when i was
a kid
nobody ever knew that my aunt would ever
would have ever done that
um
i
i was in i was a truck driver
and i had
273 pills in a ziploc bag
had a glock 9 millimeter
i walked into sleeper in my truck with
everything along with a little bitty
pint of whiskey and i said god if you
don't save my life i'm gonna die
i can't do this anymore
um
i was enroute to a town to go buy a
hollow point bullet
i couldn't do the drug addiction anymore
i couldn't do the pain
um
i got pulled over
i know it was god
he uh
they arrested me
took me to jail
and i did 10 years in federal prison on
drugs and gun
god saved my life
i
i'm not gonna lie to you it's not like i
don't crave it
i crave it every day
especially with us being on the streets
so you guys met
how and when
we met november
21st 2019.
and you're married we're married got
married the next day you got married
after one day
yes and we've been struggling
i've been fighting
every day
i i went to work one day came back
and
it's a little odd in job i was working
with someone and i was trying to get
money up so i could get me and her into
a motel room i didn't want us on the
streets anymore
i get back and find the person that we
trusted
he had gave her a roofie
had her so whacked out of her mind he
was sitting there trying to rape her
yeah he beat me he beat her well trying
to rape me he beat her and he was
literally in the process of trying to
rape her
of course i took action immediately
i beat the hell out of the guy
i ain't gonna lie i beat the hell out of
him
we're no longer friends
this boy girl's been put through so much
i've been put through so much
were drugs a part of uh
yesterday's life as well yes
and
what was she using
excuse me what was she using what was
she using
at the time she was bad on uh xanax and
oxies
um
yeah i get addicted to pills very
quickly very quickly
and it didn't help matters because i was
pretty much doing the same thing
i still do them every now and then
just to get that and just get that high
she'll do it
with me
um
[Music]
i hate it because i didn't know that she
was recovering from things
the stress of being on the streets is so
traumatic
it can
it can destroy you
um
i'm not gonna lie to you and tell you we
ain't scared
scared every day
i've had a very hard time with drug
addiction
um
she has to
you guys
are new to skid row you just got here
yesterday well we we was here we got
here uh actually november last year we
got here and we left out in march of
last year and went back to colorado
um
skid row is
not
it's not our cup of tea it's like when
we got off the greyhound bus i told my
wife i said we are to hurry from rush
and get out of here because
white people white people are not
welcome here yeah
um
so
we heard it got out of course we got
down there to macarthur park seeing it's
been cleaned up
but still couldn't find a place to stay
so we uh caught the dash all the way out
to uh echo park
and
we tried a couple of different locations
just to lay down just trying to get some
rest
we ended up finding a bridge
over by
um
burger king
and that's where we slept
i'm her husband
last thing i ever want is for her to be
on the streets i never want her to be
going through this with me
but
she does it
what is the drug that you guys
are struggling with today
what what what drug are you struggling
with today we did some uh
well not today today we did we did
we did some more piano
this morning
um
still pills
yeah yeah
um
and uh
yeah
did an oxy i dropped my beard
and she drunk her bears on top of taking
oxy
alcohol is the thing for you as well oh
my god i love my beers yes if i can have
liquor no more i'm going to drink my
beer
like now i'm my eyes coming down so we
shake and are you are you native
american i am native american okay the
blonde hair through me but uh yeah i'm
on second apache oh you are
do you have kids
no i miscarried four times oh wow
[Music]
how about you david i have no kids we
would have had kids but she miscarried
four times so
again drug addiction and alcohol is what
took them
so
that's what it is
you've been doing what with you you've
had jobs david up until now yeah what
kind of jobs
like no construction i do a little
construction shot job stuff like that
but
work
is dead end for me because nobody wants
to hire anyone on the streets right they
don't wanna
you don't know how many times me and her
have been scrutinized we've been stared
down at
we get looked at stupid and it's like
everybody has a problem
everybody has issues
some control them different than others
in our case the only thing we can do to
control the
the
situation we're in is to
you know pop our pills here and there
she drinks her beers and
it gives us a mindset it brings us back
down
because there's times we just float off
in outer space and can't even control
ourselves
um
it's hard
yeah it's real hard living on the
streets is terrible
in phoenix how have you supported
yourself before you met david
i
how did i support myself i didn't i was
this one
my ex-fiancee
from hialeah we went all the way to new
orleans because we were doing uh well he
was doing
um
fraudulent checks you know and checking
them in so we can get money but
apparently new orleans caught up to
what they were doing
and i was part of it and by that time we
already had did math
and
we got caught
and i was in paris jefferson over there
in new orleans
for seven months and i was gonna go to
prison but they found out that some of
the checks have been forged on my you
know by my name
and because of that me and my ex fiance
we were now stranded and homeless
and i didn't want to talk to him i was
so mad at him
because you know he kept saying we were
going to pull this off the other three
that was with him they're still in
prison
well now they yeah they're still in
prison now because they you know were
forging
and
before i met my husband i just kept
walking and then you know me being the
alcoholic that i was i ended up in
bourbon street
and in bourbon street people leave out
drinks and stuff so it was like paradise
for me
and i met
some dude
some mexican dude
and you know he's like if you don't have
a place to stay you can still come sleep
in my tent and then he tried to while i
was sleeping
you know he puts his hands on me and
stuff and i said what are you doing
you asked me to stay here
i didn't know you were gonna pull this
off
so i grabbed all my stuff that i
the little bit that i have
and
that i kept walking and in barbie street
there's like this
fountain or whatever next to the
riverwalk or whatever
and there's these two couples named
johnson and joe that wanted me to be in
their relationship
and
i was gonna take it because i had nobody
you know i didn't have a phone to call
my mom i haven't seen my mom i haven't
seen my family in three years
and
because of that i just you know i was
gonna go with them and then that's when
i seen my husband
and we clicked like right away
everything was obviously yeah
it was like there was like a zing there
and
what was it about each other that made
you decide you're the
marriage material after a day as
everything we do is
is the same like i'll be thinking of
something and he'll be speaking it out
without me even saying anything or he'll
do the same and then i'll say it
it's like we already our mind is already
connected
it's like when she had mentioned that
she had died four times
every time she had died i'd be laying
her in bed and i just feel her and i
already know what's gonna happen
i'll bounce up grab her snatch her up
and just do what i gotta do to get her
back
back here again and
then she starts to breathe and she's
okay
um
i can be in the deepest sleep and feel
her in a minute i feel like i'm wide
awake
um
you know because of
because of my drug addictions which i i
can't seem to kick um i have
copd i've got emphysema i got congestive
heart failure and i suffer from
testicular carcinoma
um
people look at me every time i cough and
they're like oh my god you know he's got
he's sick
he's got covered and i don't i'm not
sick with covid
i'm sick because i have you know i
suffer from copd and emphysema i got
stage three copd and stage three
emphysema
um
doctors have already said that by the
time i'm
upper 40's i'll be stuck on oxygen for
the rest of my life
we both suffer from extremely bad
health conditions
um
a lot of it is because of drug addiction
um i i do think that i met my husband
because
we had found out that jasmine had aids
so if i would have stayed with them i
would have had she would have got aids
so
we got out of that situation real quick
huh yeah my husband told joe i'll fight
you for her and he didn't want to fight
him
i told him i said i'm taking i'm taking
her away from here
well i told my shoulder i said i got i i
have a house he's got a place and when
we got there
the guy he was running from he was
running a thousand dollars a month to
sleep on a couch
and watch his phone i was i was getting
tv i was giving him a thousand dollars a
month
uh like she said i was literally laying
on the couch in the living room no no tv
i'm watching my phone and
um
i brought her to the house to bring her
in and he said oh you can stay but she
can't
i've never been on the streets a day in
my life i said well you know what i'm
not going to leave her out here by
herself i'm going out there with her
he said well where are you going to stay
and i said i really don't give a [ __ ]
where i stay i said i'm going out there
with her
and and the reason why he didn't want me
to stay there is because he wasn't
sleeping with me he wanted to sleep with
her and we wouldn't allow it so
he paid me what he owed me for back rent
and we went and got married
and
nope you've been married now for how
long married almost two years two years
yup
how was it now two years later
it's a struggle it's a struggle but we
have each other we have each other when
we make it and we still have fun you
know a lot of people say that you know
being here is stressful stressful when
they're by themselves you know i mean
her with each other it's not really as
stressful you know because we
you know we pop our little pills here
and there and she does a little drinking
and we just
go in our own little fantasy world
together you know it's just me and her
we don't have to worry about nobody else
you know
um
i said i hate that i've gotten their
strong back out on them but
sometimes it's the only thing i've got
that can keep me sane
you know
um
what it was this lifestyle that you've
been living
uh taught you which was the biggest
lesson you've learned
the biggest lesson i've learned is
don't trust the ones in your life
that
i guess don't trust the ones in your
life that you feel in your heart are
always going to do you wrong
stay away from stupid
you know ron white is one of the
toughest comedians in the world and he
always says at the end of every sermon
you can't pick stupid stay away from it
and unfortunately there's been some
circumstances we've been stuck with
stupid
and uh
but the biggest lesson i've learned is
you know have more trust in yourself
and have trust in the one you love
you know no matter how complicated or
mean or bad things can get sometimes you
know you've always got that one person
by your side that you rock
it's like i am with her
and
that's
that's the one thing
that's the one thing that's a blessing
in itself
would you guys describe yourselves as
happy with this life that you're living
no
no
no we hate it every day
but
we got to do it there's no other choice
to it we you know
it's like i've explained to her you know
the streets will either make you or
break you
yeah and they want to put us in shelters
but we don't want to we're not going to
separate it and so we just stay on the
streets it's what we do you know we're
not
we're not bad people we don't steal we
don't rob from anybody we don't lie to
anybody we don't we're not distrusted
towards anyone
we just
we have a slight addiction and
she drinks
but we're
not bad people we don't hang out with
stupid people
you know we don't
we just do us
how do you support yourselves now
believe it or
not kind of a tough question because her
mom actually helps us out financially
she sends us money not knowing that
we're going to go off and blow it on
stupid [ __ ]
but she helps us out yeah western union
she once sent us western union and here
we can't do that because they want id
they want id and when i was in new
orleans i had my idea my cigarette pack
or in my pocket it was attached to my
cigarette pack and i dropped it
and they have one sense
so
you know when the cops never pull this
over you know what are they oh you're so
scared yeah we give them all the
information they want and they're just
like okay you're free to go go you ain't
got nothing on you okay bye i'm out of
here
you know
but
um
yeah we're not
that's how that's how we've been
supporting each other still her mom your
mom sent us money and of course we
i ain't proud of it we go off and we do
stupid things with it you know
but
what's your biggest regret
my biggest regret is
that i have a lot of them
well the biggest regret is not
meeting my wife
sooner
that's my biggest regret
i wish i would have known her years
before i met her
she would have never been she would have
never went through the abusive
relationships she had she would have
never
went through anything she went through
um
and of course you know
one of the other biggest regrets that
i've ever had is not being a part of my
family's life before they all passed
away
i wish i would have been more a part of
the life instead of being a part of
drugs
but it was what it was
do you think that maybe your
your lover with phoenix your love for
phoenix might
get you to become the provider and
you need to protect her for her yes
eventually yes
i'm a big protector for her yeah but
you're still on the streets but i'm
still on the streets and but
provider i know
you know once we get our lives situated
together
she's going to be very well taken care
of
you know
we have our fights we have our ups and
downs but at the end of the day we're
still laying with each other that's any
married couple it's normal you know
we're still laying with each other still
loving each other still embracing each
other
because we know that neither one of us
can do it as separate and apart from
each other
you know
yeah i'm literally lost without him
that's great i wish you guys the best of
luck
i hope you guys figure this all out and
please
stay safe out there
thank you thank you thank you phoenix
thank you david thank you good luck out
there
you